au succès de notre dernière mission je
ne pourrais rien faire sans avoir dans
mon oreillette descend dans le tunnel il
y en a trois qui arrive une image in
mois et spire n'y avait qu'un seul
salaire des luthiers qu ils mangent une
serviette
je me suis dit est simplement analogues
je croyais vraiment que j'avais de
l'avenir comme super espionne et en fin
de compte ma vie est toujours aussi
barbante tout mettront en retrait
j'entends encore ma mère me répéter
oublies tes rêves susan elle avait gravé
sur mon cartable rina bogdanov est sur
le point de vendre une arme nucléaire
tactique à une organisation terroriste
foule au lieu dit juste ruinant pas
question elle connaît les identités de
tous nos agents
il faut pourtant trouver la gombe sans
se faire repérer je vais faire retourner
servir la cantine vous y allez d'accord
et on me dont un beau chat ça vous fera
un assistant chez pas de passer voir
patrick huile un équipement spécial pour
vous il se croit quand ton futur vous
aurez une nouvelle identité en une femme
à charmante plus petit sharp l'homme qui
m'aura n'est pas encore né
c'est gonflé à bloc
vous vous croyez prête pour mission de
terrain l'action c'est moi
tiens toi sur un scooter non mais t'es
cuit le pain vous ne devrez entrer en
contact avec aucune de vos cibles
l'atuge carrément dans la cour des
grands je suis un vrai ce point une fois
j'ai sauté d'un pont en voiture pour
atterrir sur un train alors j'étais au
feu pas la voiture j'étais en feu il ya
quelques jours ci chez vous qui
m'angoisse
mon pauvre petit césar mon père venait
ici accompagné parfois et il vous
habiller un bras d'asse dresseuse de
dauphin j'ai oublié de frapper peut-être
non mais vous vous êtes parti en est
alors lancé